[Music]
identify products based on their barcode
with seeing AI so seeing AI plays audio
cues to give you an indication of when
it first recognizes the possible
presence of a barcode the faster the
beeps the closer you are and then
eventually you'll hear a description of
what the product is so for example here
I have a DA I'm going to hold the phone
over the jar parallel with it maybe one
foot away the distance to the object
depends on how big it is the larger the
further away you would want to be so the
phone is over the jar and I'm not
hearing anything
so let's slowly rotate it until we hear
those beeps there are a beep so let's
keep going processing Barney butter
Barney and company almond butter crunchy
button
cool peanut butter I like that
let's try something else so have another
product here this time it's a box and
with a box there are six possible sides
which I'd have to scan in actual fact it
could be anywhere on those six sides so
I'm going to hold the phone quite a bit
further away this time so that the
camera can see the entire stall entirety
of one side at a time so we're not
seeing anything on that side and try
another one oh that's lucky
Annie's homegrown microwavable gluten
free mac and cheese 5 C key
Wow great so mac and cheese and I was
lucky I got it on the second side this
time so to recap we use barcodes to
identify what a product is hold the
phone over the object you want to
recognize maybe about a foot away but
you should try different distances based
on the size make sure the phone is
parallel and start rotating the object
until you hear the beeps make slight
adjustments until the beeping gets
faster and you hear the description
readout sometimes you'll hear that more
information is available like the
instructions on the package now I better
get back to putting away my groceries
Microsoft logo appears